this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer machine learning
has become so pervasive that you
probably interact with it dozens of
times a day without even knowing it when
Netflix curates movies and shows on your
homepage based on the ones you've
already watched that is machine learning
at play and the type of artwork that
appears on the thumbnails for those
shows that is also curated and selected
based on its understanding of your
preference for a different artwork to
try and get you to click and play and
keep watching if you watch a lot of
comedies Netflix is far more likely to
show you a thumbnail with Robin Williams
in it for Good Will Hunting
or if you binge rom-coms you are more
likely to get one showing Matt Damon and
Minnie Driver when you open Ober it's
machine learning platform uses variables
like weather time of day traffic and
historic data to set a price for your
trip when Google Maps warns you about a
traffic jam and directs you to an
alternate faster route this is also
machine learning working behind the
scenes when Facebook shows you targeted
ads or Amazon recommends specific items
to you this is all machine learning
working behind the scenes and while
machine learning is America ting team's
dream come true can this type of
artificial intelligence be used for more
than just pushing ads and increasing
sales what if the same tactics used by
companies to maximize their revenue
could also be used to help benefit the
human race more and more researchers are
doing just this implementing machine
learning to help with disaster relief
climate change monitoring and in
healthcare in particular recent advances
in biological and Computer Sciences are
driving scientists to use machine
learning methods for cancer research
with a recent Microsoft project aiming
to solve cancer using artificial
intelligence and other large-scale
computing initiatives working to
diagnose and treat cancer more
efficiently than ever before but how can
a computer fight one of the most complex
and deadly challenges humans face first
we need to understand what machine
learning is and how it works to put it
simply machine learning is the science
of getting computers to solve problems
without being programmed on a broad
level there are two types of machine
learning supervised and unsupervised in
unsupervised machine learning you do not
tell the network
to look for in the day that you give it
this is often used for exploring data by
helping to infer patterns you might not
recognize otherwise in supervised
machine learning you specify what
particular feature or trait you want
your model to learn about you have an
existing set of data called the training
set which contains both input variables
and an output variable you can then use
an algorithm to learn the relationship
between the input and output variables
so it can later predict an output based
on the new input data this is the kind
of machine learning that researchers can
use to sift through millions of pieces
of information to help understand how
cancers develop and what treatments will
work best to fight them one of the most
interesting types of supervised machine
learning is the artificial neural
network this type of machine learning
was inspired by the biological neural
networks present in our brains and they
are excellent tools for finding
relationships between variables in your
data set that are too complex for a
human to economists and this type of
machine learning is very powerful it's
one way scientists are predicting cancer
before it even happens by analyzing the
interaction of genes nutrients and
demographic indicators and the
relationship to cancer development teams
of researchers are using neural networks
to help predict the likelihood someone
will develop breast cancer while their
methods are complicated let's use a
simplified version of their study to
explain how neural networks work before
you can use any neural network you first
need a data set that contains lots of
the information you are hoping to
analyze in this case the training data
set contains information about the
patient's genetics demographics and
nutrition such as intake of vitamins
along with information about which
individuals developed breast cancer this
is the data that is needed to train the
neural network since with this data we
know which individuals did and did not
have cancer develop it is a data set for
which the correct output is already
known in this study 75% of the data is
used to train the network and around 25%
is reserved to later test how good the
network is operating a neural network is
composed of an input layer one or more
hidden layers and an output layer during
the training stage of the neural network
machine learning you first feed the
network your input variables at the
input layer which in our example is the
patient's age bottom
index the number of pregnancies she's
had whether or not she is pre or
postmenopausal and details of genetic
analysis along with intake of different
nutrients in their diet such as the
amount of folate vitamins b2 b6 and b12
that are consumed on a regular basis in
this example the output variable would
be whether or not the patient had breast
cancer develop represented as a zero for
no and one for yes this is a simplified
version of the inputs in this study for
explanations sake but even still you can
see that this is a ton of data and any
relationship between these factors and
cancer occurrence might not be obvious
so for the neural network to begin
learning from this data you first add
your input data at the input layer it
then flows through the hidden layers
eventually arriving at the output layer
each layer receives inputs from the
layers to its left as the inputs move
between layers they are multiplied by
random weights which can be assigned to
each of the connections they travel
along individual weights represent the
strength of connections between layers
and are the most important factor in
converting the input layer to the output
layer bias and an activation function
are also added to the input data as it
moves through the network in an example
like ours an activation function like a
sigmoid function would squash any output
results to lie between 0 and 1 as the
input data from each patient flows
through the network for the first time
it will arrive at the output layer has
some new basically random value between
0 & 1 which is almost guaranteed to be
incorrect the next step is where the
learning comes in for a neural network
to learn there has to be an element of
feedback involved this is done through
process called back propagation this
involves comparing the output that was
just produced with the output it was
meant to produce which we know since
this is still the training data set and
then using the difference between them
to modify the weights of the connections
between the layers in the network and
then running the network again the goal
is to run the network over and over
again each time adjusting the weights
and each time getting closer to the
right answer but how does the network
know which way to correct itself it
knows the outputs that it's producing
are wrong but how does it know how to
adjust the weight
the direction of getting a correct
answer it does this through a process
called gradient descent it's a process
that is used to move the network toward
the lowest possible error in its output
gradient descent is the backbone of
neural networks and as the most used
learning algorithm in machine learning
in order to carry out gradient descent
you first need a cost function a cost
function provides a measure of how far
off the guessed output is from the
actual output and it is simply a measure
of how much error there is in the
network this is typically expressed as a
difference between the predicted value
and the actual value for a given data
point you can plot the error against one
connections weight as it changes with
each iteration here is a cost function
plotted against just one weight to get
the best neural network possible we are
looking to minimize the cost function
meaning we are looking to choose the
weight that aligns with the lowest point
in the cost function so if the goal for
the network is to find the lowest point
of this function it can calculate the
derivative of the cost function with
respect to this one waist to know the
direction it needs to move towards in
order to find the local minima then
through trial and error making steps
toward the minimum the model will
gradually converge towards the lowest
value of the function
however this shows the cost function
plotted against just one weight in a
real model we don't look at the error
value for each separate connection and
weight we want to know about the error
across all connections therefore we need
a cost function that measures the
average amount that the models
predictions vary from the correct values
the mean squared error cost function is
the most common cost function used to
address this and it looks like this we
don't need to go into details about what
all this means we just need to know that
once this equation is derived and solved
it will provide the gradient that the
model needs to know the direction that
it should take in order to reduce errors
across all weights in the network then
once it knows which direction it needs
to move towards to get to the correct
weight of each connection it needs to
know how much to move in that direction
this is determined by something called
the learning rate with a high learning
rate it can cover more ground each step
but at risks overshooting the lowest
point with a low learning rate it can
confidently move in the direction of the
negative gradient since
is recalculating as so frequently which
is more precise but also more
time-consuming the learning rate is
usually determined by trial and error to
find the rate that works best for the
model the network will process the input
data in this way adjusting the weights
arriving at new outputs repeating this
process again and again until the error
is sufficiently small and the actual and
intended output coincide at this point
training is complete and you can now
test the network with the 25% of the
data you reserved for testing using our
example the neural network should at
this point be able to take the input
data for someone who developed breast
cancer and predict correctly that they
did based on their input data it should
also be able to see that based on the
input data for those that did not have
cancer that they indeed did not develop
cancer at this point you can present the
network with an entirely new set of
inputs data from a new group of patients
where you do not know whether or not
they will develop cancer and get a
pretty accurate output prediction about
how likely they are to in this example
the neural network that was used to
predict cancer had an accuracy of ninety
four point two percent this is much
higher than what humans could reasonably
predict and other studies and neural
networks have had similar accuracy rates
in predicting cancers the researchers
were then able to go on to create
further models to find the factors which
seemed to lead to higher rates of cancer
occurrence which they found to be
related to folate deficiency and
estrogen exposure and with this
prediction health care providers can
then focus on an ideal course of
treatment and address any nutrient or
hormone deficiencies or excesses as
needed in order to help prevent cancer
before it even happens these are the
very basics of machine learning using
neural networks and you can see how it
would be a very powerful tool many
researchers are using similar tools to
try to combat cancer in many different
ways Microsoft for example is pouring
tons of research into research groups
who are using artificial intelligence
and machine learning to fight cancer one
team of Microsoft researchers are using
machine learning to help oncologists
figure out the most effective
individualized cancer treatment for
their patients by providing an intuitive
way to sort through all the research
data available in recent years the
amount of data being
is astounding including patients entire
genomes oncologists say they are
drowning in information researchers are
trying to use machine learning to help
make sense of all data other research
groups are pairing machine learning with
computer vision to give radiologists a
better understanding of how their
patients tumors are progressing and yet
another team is working on efforts that
could one day allow scientists to
program cells to fight cancer which
sounds like something out of a sci-fi
movie all sorts of industries are now
adopting this technology and we'll only
see more of it as time goes on from
helping with cancer diagnosis to
recommending products on Amazon to
driving our cars machine learning is an
elegant powerful tool that we can use to
understand our world and can impact our
society in some very significant ways we
are just scratching the surface of all
the ways that it can be used and
researchers are coming up with new
applications for it all the time it's a
complicated subject but its power as a
tool can't be understated this video
just begins to scratch the surface of
machine learning and touches on just one
of money treads in the field if you've
been inspired to learn more or perhaps
have your own ideas on how to implement
this amazing technology a great place to
start learning more is brilliant
they have several courses related to
this topic including this one dedicated
to artificial neural networks in this
course you will dive into the
fundamentals of artificial neural
networks as you progress through each
section your learning is tested and
reinforced by answering fun questions if
you answer something incorrectly it does
not impede your progress instead
brilliant allows you to check the
solution and explanation so you can
correct your misconceptions and carry on
learning these courses are curated
brilliantly to bring you from a basic
understanding of science and maths to
having a deep understanding if you find
this section too difficult you can
always refresh your fundamental math
skills before returning to it or if you
are already familiar with neural
networks you can take the follow up
course in machine learning feeling
inspired then go to brilliant org ford
slash real engineering and sign up for
free and the first 73 people to go to
that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription as always thanks
for watching and thank you to all my
patreon supporters if you'd like to see
more from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter so Brad
and discord server Arabella